Her low freak bitches and
I go, I gotta go, I leave.
And then I'd never worked,
worked out of that gym again.
I was like, well, I'm done.
I can't come here anymore. I just
fucking guys trying to get my money.
Plus he's a big dude. So it was kind
of dangerous. Dangerous to say no dude.
I used to work out with David Duke
when I was growing up. Holy Shit.
We shared it back fence when I was
growing up. Holy Shit. We used to go to,
I mean that's kind of, I don't know if
you consider the Ku Klux Klan up here.
Ms came or not, but um, and he dated,
I worked at this seafood restaurant.
I was a bus boy over there and he dated
the prettiest girl that worked at the
seafood restaurant. Was this when he
was in the KKK? No, this was afters.
Nonpracticing honestly seemed like a
nice guy to, how many years ago was this?
This is 1995 so that was when
he was in the public eye.
He was like a big deal back
then. It wasn't that one.
It was it later than that,
that he was like running for public
office? Let me think. It was no,
when I was younger,
he was running against Edwin Edwards,
I believe for public office.
I was probably around 1990 or 88.
I feel like he did some
stuff after that though,
on a national level or
wasn't on a state level.
What does he run for governor
or something like that?
He ran for governor a couple times.
Yeah, him and I remember the signs.
It was cause Edwin Edwards
was a crook allegedly. And uh,
David Duke was a racist and that's what
the one of the campaign poster said,
don't vote for the racist vote for
the Crook. That was the campaign.
Jesus Christ was everywhere. She's
crying and a crook one. That man one.
That's cool. Well, we used to go to the
gym and I'll tell you this, many was,
you know, I'm not unbelievers in
his practices, but he was, uh,
he was elected to Louisiana House of
Representatives in 1989 and that year the
sitting representative resigned
his seat to become a judge.
And Duke ran in the special
election to fill a seat.
The daily beast describes
the race and writing, uh,
the off year special election in which
David Duke through himself little media
notice at first out through him.
So through himself, a little media,
nudist note notice at first
who turned himself to as a,
what they touted himself as a prolife
fiscal conservative was known as an x clan
member.
He has shooed overtly racist language
and instead pointed to crime in the city
criticizing affirmative action and
minority set asides. Hmm. Yeah.
I just did chest and Tris or them,
so I wasn't in all that, you know,
we just did basic workouts. Did he quit
like a bitch when the reps got high?
He was uh, he was, he was an animal. He
was, he was strong. He a strong man. Gai.
Yeah.
Probably a lot of people after him to
kill him probably got to be on your p's
and q's probably. And he
gave me direction. He just
gave me direction, you know,
and he didn't, yeah, like how to do it
right. He didn't conversation a ton,
but he would, yeah. This is how you do
it. This is how you do it, you know? Uh,
did you ever ask him about the clan?
I didn't ask him about that date.
I wanted to try and meet his lady did.
I was trying to mill around us.
He fucking smell a pair
of her pants alone.
Do you feel me doing when you were a
little kid? I mean, at that time I was 15
correct, bro. I never been where
wrecked and I wasn't back ever. Yeah.
Yeah.